let's go next to shayna from state
college is that uh is that state college
pennsylvania
is yes
okay yeah i don't know how how is it is
that is the town called state college i
never understood it
yeah it's uh it's the um i guess the
main campus for penn penn state
university and the town is called state
college fascinating all right well
what's going on
not much uh pleasure to speak with you
really enjoy the show i have a quick
question would you ever uh
consider doing a long form discussion
with uh jordan peterson i know you and
he have a lot of uh disagreements i
think it'd be fascinating to hear you
two go back and forth for a couple hours
sure he's been on before and he's
welcome back any time
okay
i
think that'd be i think a lot of people
would benefit from uh
from seeing that yeah i mean he may be
too big for the david pakman show now i
don't know that he would do it quite
frankly
oh is that right yeah i mean i don't
know i don't think there's a guarantee
that peterson needs needs or wants to
appear on my show right now
and i guess the other question with that
is um
what what are your current thoughts on
the uh idw and what do you say about um
because i've read different forums and
things and some people have uh placed
you
um in that crowd what do you think of
them and what's going on oh yeah i i
don't know anything about that um but
i honestly haven't thought of
thought about or seen anything about the
intellectual dark web for
i would say a year or longer i don't
know
i don't know if it still quote exists
i just have no idea whatsoever i mean do
they are they still have they disbanded
was it ever really banded um i just have
no idea it seems correct me if i'm wrong
but it seems as though the relevance and
number of mentions have declined
dramatically
that's what i've noticed as well and i
didn't even
think it was a formal group i thought it
was just sort of like a loose collection
of
similar kind of
thinkers and
and whatnot now i know um and i haven't
heard you
talk about uh
this guy very much but i don't know if
you've been following brett weinstein
and the dark horse podcast and some of
the things that they've been saying over
there yeah no i have i'm aware of the
you know
spike protein is cytotoxic phase and the
ivermectin is fantastic phase and
all these different i i am aware of
what's going on but i've i've taken
mostly
a sam harris approach where
it's very hard to really
like go point counterpoint because they
kind of put out a fire hose of stuff and
if they mention one thing you're not
prepared for or can immediately refute
it comes off as though they're really
making good points and so you know for
similar reasons as sam harris has stated
i'm not like super directly engaging
with it
that that kind of corresponds with my
take on it as as well because i i did
actually follow the um the podcast he
and his uh wife did
uh for a while but then as time wore on
i just found that i i wasn't resonating
uh with what they were
saying quite as much and i had to do a
lot more kind of digging to really
kind of see if what they were saying
squared with
you know what the vast majority of other
experts were saying and eventually i
just decided that they weren't for me
yeah that's fair that's completely fair
everybody should make informed decisions
about media consumption i'm glad you did
absolutely well i think that that's it
for me but
real of the show support what you're
doing thank you very much my pleasure
thank you so much for the call we're
going to take just a very brief break
but we're going to continue the calls so
if you're holding on to talk to me
unless you're furious at how long you've
been holding and are about to hang up in
a rage
just hold on another moment and we're
going to go right back to the discord
lines in a second
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual credit card numbers
with one click and when i use the
virtual credit card the money is taken
out of my bank account you can create
multiple cards delete them freeze them
set a spending limit on them let's say
i'm signing up for a free trial and it
requires a credit card privacy will
autofill a virtual credit card number
and then after signing up i can delete
that virtual card so i know i'm not
going to be charged again something
really useful and very practical or
let's say i'm ordering food over the
phone but i left my wallet somewhere i
don't have my real credit card on me i
can use a virtual card on my privacy
mobile app but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video